[Music]
tom patterson was on life support
his wife stephanie strathey was told
there were no treatments left
his body was overrun by a drug-resistant
superbug but stephanie wouldn't give up
hope
it all started during a vacation in
egypt in 2015 when tom got violently ill
they thought it was just food poisoning
i was vomiting
for hours it was just uncontrollable
steph was
insistent and called the doctor
and said oh you're going to be fine by
tomorrow
well
i wasn't fine
i thought we have antibiotics for this
right whatever it is modern medicine can
handle it but no no um it turned out
that it was the worst bacteria on the
planet
tom was infected with acinitobacter
baumenei a nightmare pathogen that over
time has evolved to outsmart medical
treatments
this organism is something of a
bacterial kleptomaniac it's really good
at stealing antibiotic resistance genes
from other bacteria and when we're
throwing antibiotics to somebody to try
to cure them it kills everything but
this little guy and then it just
multiplies and moves in for the kill
stephanie had seen this bacteria before
as a student at the university of
toronto this canadian is now a renowned
epidemiologist specializing in
infectious diseases even named one of
time magazine's 50 most influential
people in healthcare in 2018.
i was hallucinating so much that i was
losing touch with reality every single
cell in my body every hair was pure pain
i'm not a medical doctor so i was trying
to learn on the go
and realized that you know the chances
of him dying were getting close to 95
and yet i still thought well like
there's got to be some antibiotics that
will kill this thing right but then tom
was medevaced back to our home in san
diego and by then it was only a couple
of weeks later but now it was resistant
to all antibiotics
this nightmare bug is one of many
microorganisms that has become
increasingly resistant against
treatments used to cure infections
including antibiotics known as
antimicrobial resistance or amr it's
caused in part by the misuse of
antibiotics in health care and in
livestock for tom it meant he was out of
options
the doctors nurses people would come in
and they would say
it's futile he's going to die and i
heard that the doctors had a meeting
with me and they said look you know your
husband is not getting any better he is
now in a coma and they asked me the
quintessential question do you want to
keep your husband alive and
that was the most terrifying moment of
my life
it was an impossible decision
stephanie didn't know what to do she
turned to tom for the answer
i remember reading a scientific paper
that said one of the last sentences to
go in a dying person is their hearing
and so i asked him honey the doctors are
doing everything that they can but they
don't have anything left to fight this
thing so if you want to live i will
leave no stone unturned
don't
assume that people don't hear you when
you're in a coma stephanie asked me if i
wanted to
give up she said she loved me
and then
i heard her say if you want
me to try
to help you
squeeze my hand
and i waited
and he squeezed my hand i mean i was
ecstatic and then i thought oh crap like
what am i going to do
at the university health network in
toronto we met with dr susie hoda who
even in the middle of the pandemic is
concerned about amr
as the medical director of infection
prevention and control she's alarmed by
the lack of attention given to the
crisis even though the who declared it a
global health threat
it's interesting because in this
pandemic different countries have
experienced surges that
are of different magnitudes have
happened at different times have been
dealt with in different ways in the by
their health care system and all of that
affects their risk
of antimicrobial resistance and i have
no idea how they've managed their risks
we're not talking about that right now
because we're focusing at the problem at
hand
let's begin with the facts by 2050 it's
projected 10 million people will die
every year from drug resistant
infections but experts say that figure
is dated and in reality is far worse
because of the pandemic
one reason for this is the misuse of
antibiotics to fight the coronavirus
research from the americas showed more
than 90 percent of patients admitted to
hospital for kovid were prescribed an
antimicrobial but only seven percent
needed them
there are a number of things that have
happened through this pandemic that i
think do affect our risk of
antimicrobial resistance increasing and
certainly there have been a couple of
studies that have come out more recently
that have shown that healthcare acquired
infections but also antibiotic resistant
organisms in hospital settings have been
on the rise through this pandemic
dr hoda points to resources being
reallocated from surveillance and
prevention to deal with the immediate
emergency
facilities in the u.s and europe have
reported increased cases of superbugs
among patients hospitalized with covid
according to the cdc
i'm not sure we'll truly ever really
know exactly how much of a degree the
pandemic has played in what ends up
transpiring but it will be years before
we feel effects it's very much a
snowballing issue so if we don't address
it now it just continues to perpetuate
and get worse and worse and worse
back in southern california tom was in a
coma his organs were shutting down and
stephanie was scrambling to find a way
to keep him alive no antibiotics would
work it led her to search for a
potential cure and what she found was
bacteriophage a century-old therapy
bacteriophage or phage for short
are parasites of bacteria they're
viruses they're a hundred times smaller
than bacteria and they have evolved to
be the perfect predator of bacteria they
were actually discovered by a french
canadian felix de jarrell a self-taught
microbiologist and he was the first
person to use phage therapy on people
but when penicillin came on the scene
around the time of world war ii it was a
miracle drug and so the west forgot all
about phage therapy
this is how it works phages which kind
of look like alien spiders need a host
to survive but they're picky each phage
has its own preference and will only
hunt a particular type of bacteria or
those in the same family to gobble up
and kill there's an estimated 10 million
trillion trillion phages on the planet
they're everywhere they're in our bodies
they're in soil and water but you need
the right kind of phage to kill the
bacteria that you want to kill so it's
kind of like a lock and key
since there are more phages on earth
than bacteria finding the right match in
time for tom wasn't going to be easy
stephanie reached out to phage
researchers for help now this is the
wild part they sourced them directly
from places like sewage
barnyard waste because wherever you find
a lot of bacteria you find the perfect
predator the phage that will kill them
okay here we are we're having megan
administer phage therapy intravenous to
dr tom patterson
three weeks later they had two phage
cocktails purified to give tom
and we injected these a billion phages
one billion phages per dose even though
one of the doctors described this as
like a hail mary pass tom woke up a
couple of days later lifted his head off
the pillow and kissed his daughter's
hand
good morning
what what is it that you'd like today
oh nice
amber would you do it a hamburger we'll
see what we can do about that very good
waking up ain't like in the movies when
you've been in a coma for three months
it's a slow process your brain comes
online very very slowly
i just remember waking up and there was
my daughter
one two three up
right on
i prayed
and we were lucky and in fact we've gone
on to use this treatment to save other
lives and limbs
it's been more than five years since
phage therapy saved tom's life and
during those years stephanie and tom
have turned their anguish into action
helping those in a similar state
well you know we're going to this canyon
where there's some sewage runoff from
the neighborhood
on the day we met with stephanie and tom
they took us to a wooded area to search
for phage
we like to crawl around these places
because you know medicine comes from
strange sources these days
what tom and i often do is we try to
collect
samples um sludgy water sewage um you
know animal scat in fact there's some
skunk scat right in our backyard i
should probably put that in a container
and take it off to the lap so i got
gloves i got my trusty trowel
[Music]
they don't get too far down the trail
when they find a good spot
so this little footbridge here there's a
little creek you can see there's some
nice gummy water over here
you're not supposed to fish for weeds
well you know along with that rock we
have some sewage run off and a couple of
leaves there's beige everywhere right so
the leaves can't hurt
i mean just a drop of water can have a
trillion phages in it we're just going
to continue to collect some and pour it
into here
very sophisticated science experiments
once the samples are collected stephanie
takes us inside the lab at the
university of california san diego where
the phages will be isolated
it's here stephanie launched and
co-directs the center for innovative
phage applications and therapeutics the
first dedicated phage therapy center in
north america she shows her latest find
to the lab director
pretty fresh scott was from lafayette i
figured you know that skunk thought he
was so smart pooping on my mom i thought
you know i'm gonna get
jokes aside while the world is focused
on the pandemic stephanie is determined
to continue the fight against these
insidious monsters that are silently
spreading because samples like this
might be the only viable alternative in
a crisis where many modern medicines no
longer work
we've only started to turn our eyes back
to phage therapy because of this
superbug crisis and now there's clinical
trials being done there's a network of
phage researchers and infectious disease
physicians across canada that are trying
to get it going there and i'm trying to
help this is being upheld as the
potential answer to the superbug crisis
in the midst of a pandemic it's hard to
get people's attention for yet another
problem they want to go on with their
lives they don't want to hear about
another problem but
this is a problem that's here and
actually i'm the poster boy i'm the
experimental guinea pig if you will but
steph is the woman who really
came up with the idea and continues to
be in the vanguard
advocating for it and i can't tell you
how much i love her and appreciated that